what's your new show briar patch about
while my character is suddenly given the
news that her sisters died um she is a
police officer and died in a car bomb so
she goes back to her hometown to
investigate her sister's murder and it
just gets crazier and more wild and
weirder than that she also works for in
a Senate subcommittee so she works for a
senator who she's you know in havin a
situation with her maybe relations
relations is that why you're doing
research it was research no you are very
method that's all I think
so Austin I think it's very telling of
your character to to want a man like
that just so strong and so infinite and
knows what he wants and knows what's
good for people that's a cool dude he
isn't really very cool but it was also
research too we did he shot the pilot
for the show in September of two
thousand eighteen and then Cory and I
started dating in October of 2018 and I
remember when the show got picked up and
we started doing ADR and we were gonna
film the rest of it last year I talked
to the showrunner Andy and I was like so
art imitates life or in life imitates
art I think I have the answer to that
fine it's so crazy yeah yeah it's a cool
show yeah luckily you know when you
watch the show it's definitely more
cynical version of looking at politics
and looking at sort of the world in
general or not but yeah that's not the
case with Cory thank goodness I know no
he seems really cool I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
YouTube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this